[Music]
you're lying
i i swear to you i'm not lying i'm not
well i'm okay i'm lying a little bit but
i'm a producer and that's what i do
and i will have your money in full i
promise you you got 72 hours after that
i choked you to death
come on i'm not an idiot you haven't
painted the most accurate portrait of
our investor
all right we've been in trouble before
we always find a way out
it's all over the street you need money
why don't you guys come by this set
frank pierce is going to be there excuse
me mr pierce i'm so sorry about you okay
[Music]
frank pierce was insured for five
million dollars to scumbag he doesn't
shoot a frame or film and he makes five
million dollars well how would you felt
if all you had to show for it was a
lousy insurance check
look i got a scam what do you mean a
scam we make it look like we're actually
going to be putting together a movie
we heavily insured a star will do his
own stunts
montana yeah that's dick montana what
are you doing dude montana come on daily
game russian relax
you are perfect for this particular part
i really connected to the story yeah but
you get second western you know it's
very massive
congratulations
bang we kill him in a stunt he's dead
and then we're rich
we're rich
[Music]
duke montana if he were alive right now
i know he would be saying
where's that damn horse here duke
my god you're alive you don't know this
guy he's got like nine lives
it's not that hard to kill somebody
we're shooting this fantastic
roper's seat it's gonna be a real killer
if you want
you have to be six foot under up on boot
hill right now
i'm gonna let you down these people are
ready to die for not the best choice
awards
what kind of a human being are you well
i'm a producer
how is it a guy making a million dollar
movie don't have a better car
i don't believe in ostentatious
flamboyance
no
[Music]